ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro ro
ro
ro ro I just want to lose, so I
write that number in Journey to the West.
Everything
ordered is a recent discovery and I take
pride in it. It is judged whether it will be a review portrait
. The Korean food in Korea is
attracting attention and is causing a
boom.  I'm not a nail person,
I'm my
own reinterpretation of the cancer I've seen based on the Korean formula of Shin Soo-
an
.
Hello
, I'm Joo
Sook.  Based on the
food that I had eaten at the court, I think I
have now put on Cheonghae modernity
. Then,
modernity means having the taste of Korean food
and bringing changes to the car,
these days.  The abbreviation here unravels the clearness of the senses,
I think of the numerous things around me because they are easy to relate to incense cuisine, and
inputting information to express it unconsciously
is the style that the food that I think is inspiration.
The
sense of joining is a synthesis of these things,
except for the shape of the container. I heard that there are a lot of those tendencies, so I
can see
that I like natural cool, so
my reasoning is comfortable.
spooler came so far 72
is coming. This is
Lee Bong-joo, a Korean gaming master
.  spurt
then 0 times
then more than my dam every now that
Holy Spirit ugg heat treatment again, I do
n't go to my 10th, and now it
's raw ribs, so there's something like that. At the
end, Qualcomm is just
over.
There are many cases where there
are foods like this and now I am
surprised, but
I want to
show that there is such a
food of Korean food.
I think
it's very important to eat while sharing a certain intention and
thought, so I
pay a lot of attention to the formation
[Music]